hello and welcome to this video playing
fmg nail um yep okay let's go for
communes gambit oh very early trade it's
not super dangerous for black but still
a very solid option for white not a bad
opening or anything let's see yeah
Bishop f5 i think is good in this
particular case if i'm not mistaken i
can actually go with g5 in this position
as Queen B 7 g KX h for Queen a 8 and
Queen B 6 is good for black but the last
time I think I looked at this like a
couple of years ago so i hope i'm right
with this now i'm actually ready for
Queen B 6 without him being able to him
oh that's that's very very modest just
take on b6 letting black take it's often
more interesting but ok anyway I think
I'm here black is quite comfortable with
a file open be five before coming looks
nice he doesn't have a name right oh
groups Cuba well we don't know it's an
American flag got many games played
right
okay so before is an option yeah I think
I'll go for that it's just accelerating
my development as well and that maybe
have rugae to as a direct threat here
yeah I think I had to actually after
Luke a two it's quite difficult to keep
that pawn protected
ya know okay too it's not possible but
still what to do yeah I can I wonder
what I do with my Kenya again still a
castle huh but i don't i don't really
know if I want to do that
I wonder if 94 is interesting just tried
to be annoying with this pin yeah not
sure about it I still have no no again
okay to is a possibility
yeah okay after I was just about to
suggest that move that looks kind of
okay but maybe um maybe I can shoot for
FR therefore in this position I'm not
sure about this emitting this Bishop is
some quite interesting I can also be
very direct here just that takes you
three play okay too it's not bad
probably well it's it's a bit it's a bit
crude may be centralized and then f5
okay let's go at five pm and not sure
about this five if I want to do that if
I bro gave a threatening f4 it gives him
but should be three yet okay let's not
think about this form for too long Jack
yep that was definitely okay for him now
hmm now okay seven is some it's just
around the corner hmm and Knight b6 I
cannot play due to Bishop b5 huh yeah
that that I didn't play well at all
Wow
badly plate and that Bishop b5 I have to
play Luke h7 first I wanted to play rook
age seven and 96 yeah and and I play it
in the wrong order and now he takes like
20 seconds and then he plays the move to
annoy me yeah my one of those games very
stupid play yeah I have to go rook h7 I
wanted to do this this and this and I
think it's probably roughly equal which
is bad of course because after the
opening I already had an advantage here
I'm better so I shouldn't be in a
situation where I'm slightly worse maybe
94 was was a bit too lame I don't know I
mean okay this still looks okay but
probably maybe this f5 move method that
I wasn't sure about it all if I want to
use this idea or not and probably I
shouldn't play that it's more flexible
to to wait with the smooth now probably
probably White has sense roughly
equalized i mean this this kind of
opening play here with the with queen
bee three taking on b6 this is some yeah
it's not particularly good but maybe not
bad enough to be two leading into a
clear clear problem okay maybe this is
better this is now given by the computer
threatening to win that porn and that is
more precise actually because he has to
do this and now I'm playing this
threatening before I this is a lot
better actually Kim that's interesting
interesting fact yeah i played this
really quickly i mean i had this kind of
position often in some years ago 94 is
again a stronger and then there's ya 92
is a good defense i'm really not sure
maybe it's also better here to to not to
not rate this and just just send relies
him no it's it's a bit more comfortable
for black in any case but here after
this age four years equalized jan and
now i have to play this i wanted to play
rook age 796 and I just I just confused
to move water but i forgot that i have
to have to have to do this first we have
this is what i wanted to want it to play
and he I think it's roughly equal my go
king he m and Bishop p.m. so does it's
it's roughly equal this is looking nice
but he's not doing that much am ok
thanks for watching